[Music]
look everyone knows by now that Disney
logos take forever and almost always
very slightly to match the theme or
setting of the film I here by a petition
that's in God's to let us heretofore
save time and effort by just sinning
Disney the way we always have sinned
Comcast he sings the lyrics underneath
the lovely England sky and that the next
cut is this bleak ash is Oliver Lee
London inside come on what Jack steals
this Apple but immediately gives it to a
random stranger as if somehow that makes
him less of an asshole
now those the same steps and birds from
the feed the birdsong in the first movie
it's not to feed the birds lady dead on
the steps at the st. Paul's Cathedral
movie took a dark turn fast this
painting looks even less like a real
city than in the first movie look
nostalgia is all fine and good but among
the things you didn't need to copy from
the first movie was the insufferable
habit of running free credits may have
flown 50 years ago but this is 2019 and
we want to pop some bottoms already
spoilers the other day I found the
butcher sack hanging on the coat rack on
my hat was in the larder isn't his
England any card in this movie but since
I don't want to Google every single
London phrase I'm just going to pretend
every word or phrase I don't understand
as a sexual euphemism also the last time
I asked my college girlfriend if I could
put my hat in the larder it was my
butcher sack that ended up on the coat
rack we are solicitors with the law firm
of Gordie Cordray Gooding and Frey so if
we want the first names would be pig Rob
Cuba and Channing it seems you have
fallen three months behind in your
payments let me know when he gets up to
ten months and is hiding his car under a
pile of dead leaves to avoid
repossession what if you are enabled to
pay in full by Friday at midnight I'm
afraid we will have to repossess your
home ah good old repossession it's long
been a staple antagonist tool in films
and if I read the tea leaves correctly
they will get to keep their home in the
end father left two shares in the bank
you could use those to pay off the loan
I was saving those for the children
worried about the children after you've
paid off this massive debt and kept your
home all these decades later and crazy
can a neighbor is still allowed to get
away with this bull and you have to go
to work no what can wait well that
certainly is what's the word
conventional no coming up no it's not it
lazy story writing yeah that's the one
not one single shot in this movie has
shown a London sky that is pretty or
even not ugly I'd remove four hundred
sins if the balloon lady turned out to
be penny wise sadly she does not
were always fond of magic well the open
scissors they're stored above your lamp
suggests these rooms were also always
full of danger snows led the lane but
the cherry trees forgot to blow pick me
up this song is on with the adventure I
honestly can't remember why he kept most
of this stuff to begin with that's
because you didn't last time we saw that
globe Mary Poppins was putting it in her
magic bag when she abandon you the first
time you sadly Georgie already knows he
will float too and you were chasing
after an apparition Georgie is dead and
he's never coming back let go already do
you want string burn because this is how
you get string burn how do you know our
names because she's Mary Poppins coach
nice to see you jack his name is Jacky
is the lantern God and there's a million
things he hasn't done but just you wait
just you wait also if there are some
rules this world could clean up it would
primarily be in the who knows Mary
Poppins and can and can't remember her
superpowers and why Department Jack says
he worked for Bert as a kid and met her
then somehow he remembers based on one
small encounter yet the banks children
had many adventures were there 24 years
ago and they've forgotten her bag of
tricks and I will insist on having every
second Tuesday Oh coming soon to Disney
plus what does Mary Poppins do every
other week that she needs time off for
and why are so many men in London
smiling every other Wednesday every
second Tuesday this fall on HBO
I mean Disney Plus these things when we
were young they didn't really happen I
know ridiculous movie blatantly rips off
the got older and decided the magic from
my youth was just a dream angle from
hook only I'm not having it
I should have left you in the umbrella
stand but with the games
that's Kanis Disney's Tim Burton's Willy
Wonka's Mary Poppins
[Music]
still better than Aquaman I think this
entire movie Mayo itself to people being
firmly on the seagrass if you know what
I mean
that's not how sudden bubbles work not
possible for those three bubble pops to
result in all three kids being in the
tub boat
well the document dad's worried about
finding is 100% definitely on the back
of this drawing but I don't know is if
the movie intended to reveal about this
early or not it's a sin either way so
man the UK tourism board must can hate
this movie who would ever want to visit
the dreariest place in the world
miss penny farthing is the daughter of
mr. peso dollar and mrs. Deutsche Mark
Canadian dollar I sure do hope this
movie explains why Harry artless here
has such a raging destruction boner for
the banks family considering there's
really no coherent reason to be screwing
them this badly also we clearly see him
turn from Baker to Bonham in the book
where was the bank sheet in the first
place also also wouldn't there have been
another shareholder on the back of that
sheet even in the sequel here is a huge
mansion that forces three offspring to
share a single bedroom dicks now Georgie
is cutting up check offs trying to patch
up the kite hello jack I understand jack
has used a client but this isn't a
conversation you could have had from the
ladder or the ground I guess he wanted
to be in the room where it happens are
we busy
Richie I know Poppins knows this guy but
to the banks he's just a stranger
covered in soot who has his uncle Biden
hands on Georgie shoulders and is about
to join them on the adventure inside of
a painting on a bowl ah looks like we're
in China so it's bacon grown let's see
now this should do it except no we're on
the brink of an adventure children don't
spoil it with too many questions
weird Jim Jones said the same thing okay
this is not a music hall
it is a tent one thing you should know
about Mary Poppins she never explains
anything no Sherlock
we've all been watching you in the
nursery for you this is creepy actually
kids are entitled to a reasonable
expectation of privacy in their own
bedroom well from everyone except their
parents of course even if you filled
that balcony with water it's nowhere
near as much water as a whale would need
whale it's not a fucking amphibian you
know they're water creatures Newton
frogs can chill with only ten percent of
their body and water no problem
whales can fucking knock D flat major
otherwise known as C sharp major but go
on with your lesser used key signature
names Poppins also you wouldn't need to
say major just tell them the song is in
D flat they'll know it's major by the
fact that you didn't say minor
he would read me lots of stories when he
wasn't on the source casual alcoholism
did Mary Poppins just do a pelvic thrust
while singing open it up and take a look
I promise I'm not trying to cock me
block anyone here but the burlesque
seems just a little out of place here no
give us the one about the dirty rascal
wide on truck doesn't that one a bit
wrong well too quick you're into it the
quick you're out of it I mean I'm not
the only one hearing this right so the
queen of the nation made a Royal
Proclamation to the missus absolutely no
one will be seated during that we had to
let him wrap a bit Hamilton portion of
the movie yes looking the bird also
Lynne sins and sends penguin friend who
spins end over end ascends descends but
Lynne pretends to my chagrin that the
tailspin is not his end and grits yeah
let's go get your brother back I
remember when we cared about the bank's
house and Daddy and auntie's quest to
find the bank share certificate that
feels like six years ago this thing
turned into back to the future of Sleepy
Hollow quickly I have the same reaction
whatever IP in the dark ah the old it
was all a dream or was it cliche looking
for the place where I lost things good
the lost and found good will Memphis
trust she's always there watching yes
you grow I don't remember the first
Poppins movie needing to rely on a dead
parent in order to pull the audience's
heartstrings
this feels kind of cheap Mary Potter
Harry Poppins so we went into a painting
with a suit covered street worker now
we're literally going to stand on the
ceiling does this seagull have any
original beats to hit no but the oven
and just like that thousands of Oscar
voters mysteriously streep their pants
this song basically just names a bunch
of things that are opposites there's
nothing to be holy crap that's Meryl
Streep everyone take a picture and make
gifts because this is what slumming
looks like and I'm saying that about a
woman who was in - Mamma Mia movies this
is my cousin Qasim clarifying cousin
hood
if you ring super skip a fragile skeptic
XP Alice skip this let's do the total
strain this movie is 2 hours and 20
minutes long sharing an experience that
requires physical closeness as a
metaphor for a budding romance cliche
looking the other way while the kids in
your care go rogue hope they don't get
kidnapped on their way to whatever the
task you're hoping they will complete
not another word
MARY POPPINS let's dad scream at his
children for the second time because she
can't just tell him about the secret
papers he has to I don't know learn
something seemed a pretty decent father
when they started though unlike the
original film where both parents were
clearly terrible and negligent this
looks really fucking danger what the
fuck do I care
Louise jobs to like the way first
Chimney Sweeps and now Leary's I can't
wait until Mary Poppins 9 has run out of
obsolete occupations and we get a
rousing rendition of life's a bowl of
cherries as a group of cheering night
men go around emptying people's
outhouses yes let's do take the children
into the sewers yes rattling clay Leary
speak is according to Jack and this song
replacing real phrases with phrases that
rhyme which is in a language so much as
it's a talent a lame-ass talent even Kid
Rock can rhyme and thousands of phrases
can rhyme with then we went to the bank
so English to Leary translation is easy
and the reverse next to impossible this
is not a language you invented rhyming
you invented rhyming x-games she really
is a great nanny though now they've
given each small child an arson stick to
dance with so you've been off filling
the children's heads with stuff and
nonsense
it's literally her Brandt dude don't act
so surprised I know they're children my
children and I will deal with them as I
see fit
now leave us to it in case you thought
that direct copying of the original was
over this one is also about a father who
needs to listen to his children if they
do this in the third one I swear to Walt
I'm calling it the merry pop and daddys
trilogy
well you didn't help I feel like the
only lesson this guy is learning here is
how to be an even bigger asshole
[Music]
he's crying because his kids are super
average singers and his last stitch plan
to pull the family out of financial ruin
was to go the Von Trapp route now run
along
wash your hands get ready for dinner
we're having crackers some people think
a great deal too much of that I'm sir I
know all right well I think at all when
you can just keep making the exact same
movies over and over there's that reveal
everyone saw coming an hour ago poppin
smiles knowingly now that they have
found the certificate of shares and yeah
they had a family healing moment a bit
ago but honestly they were doing okay as
a family I just needed money she shows
up knows where the money is and tells no
one all so she can feel justified for
existing this movie should have been
Poppins free and over in 30 minutes of
drawing on the back of an important
document used to patch up an old kite
this is a Brady Bunch episode not a
movie also this dunderhead daddy just
over here drawing sketches on the backs
of important documents he's the movie's
real villain have you ever ridden a bus
full of this before please have
different gonna be from riding an
innocent well pretty condition the
weight balance is so messed up here they
should crash immediately the B breeze
gonna have their way to die this movie
about a bunch of ridiculous magic
happening is going to turn back time by
having humans literally move the hands
on big bet instead of just using magic
to literally turn back time this is
basically all a big punt and we like
puns here at cinemasins but not as movie
climaxes you climbed all the way up here
without an idea this movie is set in the
1930s in Big Ben transition to electric
power in 1908 so these gas-jet shouldn't
be gas jetting so let me get this
straight she let jumping jack flash
light in his eerie Leary's risk life and
limb cobbling together a ladder pile and
performing a death-defying jack a pole
when she could have just flown up there
and Mary X pop Vinick at it herself tell
me again that Mary Poppins is a good
person I dare you that's not how clots
work that's not a medal works man it's
not how nany arm strength works he's so
angry about banks maybe keeping his home
wait how could anyone this openly and
obviously Petty and resentful and purely
evil ever rise to any position of power
if the good lawyer was just going to let
the banks in why did we need that whole
kite in the window thing now the one
thing they need is proof it's out of
their hands
in many ways flying that kite into the
room is the stupidest thing they could
have done Roger that what a dick man
also they got Dick Van Dyke back but not
Mary Poppins herself Julie Andrews oh
wait she probably has to see the script
and then turn them down I'm back for out
so none of this movie needed happened
they just had to tell Dick Van Dyke and
we'd all be good in tonight's show the
role of Gandalf seagulls will be played
by a talking parrot umbrella that
tuppence is grown into quite a tidy sum
enough to pay off that around you two so
in less than 30 years they grew four
cents to tens of thousands of dollars I
need some dick in my life wait aa sudden
Murder She Wrote
am I not early enough for the turtle
club this is the NHANES maketh man mr.
Rader locked er what is wrong with you
well I don't do tall tall
[Music]
I did not that pig Milton to get a lead
role justice I am a second-rate
celebrity like you too